let's get perspective on what's going on
with North Korea and more from Gabriel
DeBenedetti national correspondent at
New York Magazine Gabe good morning good
morning where do we think the situation
with North Korea really is at this point
well it depends on who you're listening
to if you listen to the president you
actually aren't really sure he certainly
says well actually this meeting might
happen it might not happen but you know
all indications are there's still some
back channeling going on between the two
nations there's still some willingness
to get something done of some sort do we
expect to see a meeting at any point in
the next few weeks I'm not necessarily
clear right now do we know what happened
was it a breakdown in communications was
it strategy what was it well no we don't
is the short answer there seems to be a
lot going on in the White House with
different advisors talking to the
president about whether they like or
don't like the way that North Korea is
talking about different Americans
involved in all this of course Kim
jong-un had some harsh words for Vice
President Mike Pence the president
Donald Trump did not like that so he
called everything off but then again you
also have people including the Secretary
of State the national security adviser
all saying different things to the
president here there clearly seems to be
some sort of disconnect we're just not
sure exactly where it is the other news
making big big news this week of course
was the ongoing Russia investigation and
the briefing that top lawmakers got
about classified intelligence from the
Justice Department where are we left at
the end of this week after those
briefings and and the fight over them in
essence well a whole lot of confusion
which of course has been the theme here
over the last few weeks with this
investigation those briefings in
particular got pretty testy because a
lot of Democrats thought it was quite
inappropriate that the White House was
trying to insert or not insert one of
the president's lawyers to the meetings
and there seems to be some disagreement
over what kind of involvement that
lawyer actually had where this leaves us
though is continued partisan bickering
on Capitol Hill over the president's
attempts to really monitor what's going
on in these meetings or what's going on
in this investigation and when you have
the president out there talking about
whether or not there was a spy implanted
is in his campaign something that
Democrats say is just totally not true
there seems to be a lot of confusion in
the public which perhaps is what the
White House wants the New York Times had
a report also now that Michael Cohen the
the president
attorney had a meeting with a Russian
oligarch just days before the
inauguration what does that mean for the
Muller investigation well it means the
investigation continues to be much
broader than most of us realize it can
use to get broader yeah absolutely and
perhaps much broader than even the White
House realizes there seems to be so many
more meetings that we knew about so many
more characters both in the American and
the Russian side but an important thing
to remember here is because Michael
Cohen is involved in this part of it it
also shows us that a number of these
different scandals or controversies that
the White House is wrapped up in are
actually more closely involved than we
might realize of course Michael Cohen is
known right now for being central to the
stormy Daniel saga which many people
think of as totally separate from the
Russian saga but now we hear that he's
actually meeting with Russians right
before or right during the transition
there seems to be a lot going on here
a number of states held primaries on
Tuesday ahead of November's midterms
were there any surprises and those there
were no huge surprises but there were
some small upsets and I think one of the
main takeaways here particularly on the
Democratic side is that you're seeing
enormous energy behind women candidates
over and over again women candidates
keep winning in these primaries
including in some where they're not
expected to win you know what prize in
Lexington Kentucky that's exactly one of
the ones that I'm referring to where you
had Amy McGrath the fighter pilot beat
the mayor of Lexington Jim Gray who was
the favored there and what basically she
harnessed was at this enormous amount of
grassroots energy behind a number of
women candidates all over the country
and that's why you see more and more
Democratic women running in winning you
know that works right now in the
primaries can they carry that forward to
the midterm election this is the huge
question and especially in a case like
the one in Kentucky where Amy McGrath
who won this race was not actually the
favored candidate of the National Party
there's a bit of worry over whether she
can win a general election in a
conservative area like that this is the
big question and right now we're not
sure but Democrats are certainly
confident feels like we were talking
about the midterm elections as soon as
the election gave DeBenedetti thank you
Gabe thank you